no the point of it's okay to be white as
a saying was to prove that even saying
something as mediocre as that would
result in your exact reaction right now
calling it racist yeah
because they're picking a race and
they're making a generalization saying
it's okay it's okay to be white I'm
saying like I love black women that's a
racist statement that's not just a
racist statement it's proving the point
of the meme right now your reaction they
didn't say anything good or bad it's
okay there's Big R racism which is like
systemic hateful like they're my race is
better than that race then there's
little our racism where you're just
talking about race it's just a racist
conversation like it's okay to have a
racist conversation as long as you're
not like systemically racist you know
what I'm saying changing the definition
of word there's two different ways to be
racist and one is like the hateful one
that everyone's trying to avoid then the
other one is like you pick out a race
and you make all these generalizations
about it but that's not what it's okay
to be white was that was what they were
just generalizing like it's okay to be
this race and it's like I get it it is